[Music]
a project harangues the scientists that
must be carried out between minutes it
's a crime on a subject
if the end of May
because they have a scientific project
whitacre German
onsight
cwi
it's going well hello my name is mathieu
de  waiting for a beautiful day full of
celebration and science that everyone
learns things including the jury
because we are not at all
specialists
I would really like them to be
passionate about their subject
I try to be  comfortable that they are trying
to also nato want space in
fact on stage
for the audience to be captured now
i feel a little more comfortable
speaking in front of people collaborating the
necessity wow  smile smile an
audience knowing that it was the first
time to take
mujahid makaya dad
I also liked the group without the
town hall however I ask you is is
interesting forced from a scientific point of view
here
monique younès com
jack bauer
you like
in bastia  on the roadstead of the forests
then
there is good to win the final of
on the front on the price of biblical bread
and some brave people
some epic critics
English English is really a language that
allows
the rails
tel
[Music  ]